und dann würde ich sagen ich sterbe
jetzt weil ich nichts zu essen mehr habe
16 level sind weg meine sachen sind
gesichert aber wie unnötig ist das denn
bitte
da sind wir zurück in minecraft über
projekte job aber ich habe gesagt dass
jetzt noch ne runde aufnehmen einen tag
später ich bin nicht gestorben
ausnahmsweise mal haben wir die
statistik ein bisschen zurecht gerückt
soll ich jetzt zu dem pferdchen da
hingehen oder oder wie soll ich das
jetzt machen
ich denke ich ich versuche mir hier erst
mal eine vernünftige rüstung in die
zusammenzukratzen
was ich mir denn dass die diamanten
machen aus den diamanten könnte ich mir
mal theoretisch da diamond wer ist der
bob diamond giants mein gott alter wie
das aussieht tischler dass man die
putzfrau die kommt dann fallen die
kommentare hätten locker land das war
den kon ii.de regelt us-forscher so dann
mache ich jetzt hier aus eben noch eine
schöne rüstung so das mache ich nicht
schön daran die mir noch zwei dann kann
ich mir noch schön links machen was ist
das hier eigentlich images plate achter
sehe ich noch mehr sachen hin tun
münchen oder so was will ich
cool also wenn es das ist was ich mir
denke was es ist dann ist es cool so
während du hier noch so ein bisschen
dahin brutzelt kann ich ja schon mal
hatte ich trau mich nicht ich möchte
noch mindestens ein kleidungsstück
machen noch irgendwie so ein helm oder
so ich habe ehrlich gesagt gerade ein
bisschen angst vor diesem pferd und ich
will jetzt auch umgehen sterben und ich
habe auch gar nicht zu essen mehr fällt
mir dann auch so aufnehmen
eigentlich müsste ich das auch gerade
ausnutzen dass ich hier so ein bisschen
ruhe habe und so ein bisschen laufen
kann eigentlich dass ich immer
weiterkommen in die richtung aber ich
brauche halt wirklich erst mal was zu
essen aber wo kriegt dann etwas zu essen
her kaum schlaf mein kopf darauf kommst
du dann nicht mehr kommt natürlich
erzählt mein gott das hat er mir gegeben
kobjoll retails black metal
wahrscheinlich gut aber ich hab echt nix
zu essen ich habe knochen
ich habe einen sandkuhl die brauche auch
nicht mehr die wurden pécs
sonst bald ich erst mal das aber das ist
traurig alte dass ich nichts zu essen da
wohl aber wie komme ich denn das
pferdchen böse auf mich
stoppt diese aufmärsche oder sommer etwa
1 nicht ich rechne gleich erst mal lena
an dem fernen reicht das schon für rose
das müsste eigentlich reichen oder bei
mir ist noch eine hose und leggings und
dann brauche ich noch drei aber wo
kriege ich denn jetzt was zu essen her
bisheriger bestandteil der folge luca
sucht nach essen bzw fragt sich wo er es
näher bekommt er suche nach essen der
frag einfach ob er was bekommt aber das
ist schillig mit kimba wood
ich kann es übrigens auch ausstellen
wenn ich trage drückt lasse glaube ich
habe ja schon mal im singleplayer
irgendwann mal vor sehr langer zeit
damit mein komplettes haus zerstört mit
dem team bot was auf einem baumhaus war
bz was hauptsächlich aus holz bestand
das war kein baumhaus aber es bestand
hauptsächlich aus holz und ich wollten
wir uns ein richtig cooles haus bauen so
als wolle und so aber dafür brauche ich
hätte gesagt schafe und für schafe dafür
brauche halt wolle und für volleyball
schafe und ich finde halt keine schafe
aber es ist mir scheißegal ist dieses
pferd eigentlich immer noch meine
schüchen hier machen
ja genau dann nehme ich euch beiden
damit
so dass wir auch cool wenn man sich zu
einen also diese beiden und diese beiden
soll hier rein und daran dass sich so
quasi zwei verschiedene hätte so einen
diamant schon ein eisen tue ich mein
spricht eigentlich nichts gegen so die
ziehe ich mir jetzt noch an david feed
ach so ich dachte ich könnte mir jetzt
auch erzielt wird sortiere ich mal so
ein bisschen mit inventar hier wiegt das
sonst auch mal machen so hier kommen die
fackeln hin da die schaufel und da die
und das war's so und jetzt luca zieht
auf in richtung laufe ich überhaupt
richtig da muss auf jeden fall auch noch
ja dahin muss ich ca gut ich hoffe mal
dass ich auf dem weg noch ein bisschen
ich nehme hier von erst mal was mit dass
ich auf dem weg noch ein bisschen detail
finde
wisst ihr bescheid das sind auch
schultersieg des wahnsinns alter dass
die kann ich doch boxen oder schaffe ich
das ja man beide tot vor
hab ich mich erschrocken alter auch die
geben mir sogar dings punkte
die gehen ja sogar fleisch stimmt ich
kann einfach mops töten darum sind
schafe leute ich bin ich bin im himmel
alter ich habe schafe gefunden ich habe
fressen ein bisschen was okay ganz klein
bisschen nur aber ich habe wenigstens
ein bisschen was leute geil alter geil
ich hoffe mal nicht dass das irgendwie
einen haken dran ist wer da sind schon
wieder so komische konstruktionen in den
bodden trend da hinten sich schon wieder
diamanten
das ist ehrlicher mann soll eine auf
nennt hat man die zeit des todes und das
sind soviel alter daraus kann ein
komplettes ehebett bauen so ok drei habe
ich bisher auch okay jetzt habe ich
sechs cooler gibt drei und die anderen
drei zusammenleben 3 wo soll ich denn
hier anfangen da sind wieder diamanten
schillig also das ist echt krass ich hab
schon diamant rüstung jetzt ich gucke
mich einfach mal um wohl diamanten sind
hier
ich meine jetzt ich kriege würfel
diamanten
da bringen wir jetzt auch die ganze das
ganze reisen quasi nichts mehr trotzdem
noch des eisens reisen kann man ja
bestimmt auch noch für etwas gebrauchen
sonst wäre er nicht da bin zu viele
diamanten die ab das nämlich noch mit
wir sind ich möchte nicht dass die
folgen daten auf ihr diamanten und es
ist jetzt schon wieder nacht was freuen
darf sich demokratisch losgelaufen war
so lang da unten drin dass jetzt schon
wieder nach wird egal wir können ja
jetzt uns eigentlich auch mal trauen bei
nacht loszulaufen
oder ich mache jetzt hat gleich und die
dann kurz duschen während hier macht ist
und da komme ich einfach wieder und
nehmen dann auf wenn tag ist dass könig
machen weil ich habe echt keinen bock
auf macht schon wieder
dann bleibe ich einfach kurz die stehen
lockt mich ausland lockt mich wieder
anwendern nacht ist da läuft jetzt eben
wieder zurück zu meiner hat da hinten ja
mach ich oder ich mache einfach eben
schnell ein bettchen beziehungsweise ich
muss erst mal ganz schnell wieder zu mir
ins häuschen kommen bevor hier irgend
etwas das mich nur ansatzweise bumsen
könnte ok ich hab' rüstung ganz gut und
ich habe in jeans worten ich bin
eigentlich auch richtig hübsch in dem
spiel seht ihr mich an ich bin der
hübscheste einfach bleibt man lokal
anlass mal den koran einfach es ist
einfach alter was hast du deine mutter
da hinten ok oh das natürlich jetzt
nicht gut
das natürlich optimal so dass auch ja
ich baue jetzt ein bettchen und zwar aus
schönen holz um holz mit schönen rolle
eigentlich schön schlafen da muss jetzt
mal mehr seinen komischen stopp machen
ich hoffe nicht dass jetzt irgendwie
monster kommt gibt es ein gag nicht mehr
mittlerweile bekommt noch mit und jetzt
bekommt schnell bekommt mitte war
damit kommt
ich brauch echt mal jetzt langsamer zu
fräsen jungs ii
ich könnte sogar noch den giants sport
machen da oben sich wieder diamanten
also das ist echt so krank hätte ich
mehr zu essen
ich hätte nur diamanten am start wird
nur laufen und nur diamanten bekommen
die folge ist einfach eine diamanten
folge dass es einfach so ich finde
diamanten und ich finde wieder diamant
und wäre nicht die diamanten abbau
findet wieder neue diamanten und
währenddessen fand ich einfach mal so
ein berg runter aber das macht mir gar
nichts
das macht mir gar nichts die station das
ist komisch da kommt nämlich emerald und
teile die anderen teile raus
kopper o'barry ist das denn alles
wertvoll ich weiß es ja noch gar nicht
weiß ja nicht ob das wertvoll ist aber
nicht ihr könnt mir immer schreiben
kommentare der letzten folge nicht
gesehen weil wegen ich nehme direkt
jetzt weiter auf eine schlaue zuschauer
das bemerkt dass ich das letzte mal
gesagt habe so dann könnte ich
theoretisch ja wieder über den berg
drüber und dann würde ich ja eigentlich
wieder diamanten bekommen oder auf der
anderen seite lange diamanten ich denke
dass ich jetzt mal 15 minuten aufnehmen
werde bei letzten habe ich ja schon 20
minuten aufgenommen soll er immer
zumindest gleich bleiben ca ich muss so
viel noch laufen mehr leute wo man jetzt
diamant eigentlich baualter downton
scheiße ich ein bisschen hoch ich bin
ein bisschen sehr hoch und die sie da
unten skelett ich habe einfach gar keine
rüstung soll ich einfach runter gehe nie
ohne machen er ich weiß nicht oder er so
ein bisschen weg kommen leute wir sind
jetzt ein bisschen vorsichtig ne man
muss man natürlich auch mal irgendwann
sein
es geht hier natürlich immer noch um
leben und tod und es geht auch um upload
störe ich mein ab laut speer ist nicht
für mich dafür dass ich nix hochladen
darf ich möchte natürlich auch
vorankommen diesem projekt und man
möchte natürlich auch den zuschauern
unterhaltung bieten sich hier und ich
habe auch gesagt dass bei mir
projektiert was ich regelmäßig hochladen
werde
allerdings ist es natürlich nicht
möglich
ok damit das hat mir niemand gesagt dass
da oben auf dem krieg als papa warum
sitzt wäre ich einfach explodieren
scheiß creeper ich bin froh dass
mittlerweile eine rüstung habe und dass
ich ein bisschen ungeschoren davon
kommen aber trotzdem darfst du bitte
gerne explodieren
okay ist tot den denksport dahinten
schaffe ich mir selber noch zu holen
mir ist mich nicht mit einer geschossen
lasst mich jung ich hab rüstung alter
leg dich nicht mit mehr ankläger war
schluss bei dem model s bogen fallen
junge läuft bei dem so was meist den weg
ach komm junge reddit fließen es ist mir
jetzt doch scheißegal was ihr das essen
das überhaupt gut wir sind mehr oder
weniger wir gewappnet wir brauchen noch
ein bisschen fleisch eigentlich
wir brauchen eigentlich echt fleisch
damit wir hier ein bisschen acht idee
als solche noch mitnehmen damit wir hier
mal ein bisschen ich dachte ich hätte
schon wieder geboxt aber das fleisch nur
ein wenn man keinen hunger mehr hat
stirbt man doch oder
heute stimmt es dass man dann stirbt
wenn ja
alter nehme
man spürt doch jetzt nicht ernsthaft
wenn ich doch kein essen mehr habe oder
alter stimmt das so bin ich eigentlich
so gelb in der face gehen wieso ich
sterbe wenn ich kein essen mehr haben wo
soll ich denn essen herkriegen ich kann
mir nicht einfach was ausschneiden
ich könnte mir theoretisch ganz schnell
die kiste bauen und da meine sachen
reintun alter
mehr ohne witz alter was mache ich denn
jetzt
ich könnte wenn ich wirklich deswegen
sterbe ich jetzt einfach auf den server
nochmal und bauen jetzt einfach so
schnell es geht irgendwie kiste
sogar kommt erstmal so wichtige sachen
reinheit
ja ich hab richtig gesehen man stirbt
ok ja gut welt kann ich jetzt auch
nichts daran ändern da ist meine kiste
ja ich könnte jetzt noch ein bisschen
eingraben auch überhaupt nicht auffällig
so die diamanten hier und dann würde ich
sagen ich sterbe jetzt weil ich nichts
zu essen mehr habe
16 level sind weg meine sachen sind
gesichert aber wie unnötig ist das denn
bitte ich weiß wie ich bin mal fahrt
aber ich hatte doch gar keine chance mir
irgendwas zu essen zu holen
da war ja ich hatte gar keine chance es
war quasi unmöglich dass ich mir irgend
etwas zu essen holen irgendetwas
ansatzweise zu essen
ein grabstein kann auch keiner dahin
holen
dass ich jetzt weiterspielen könnte als
held ärgerlich um die 16 level aber ich
bin jetzt froh auf jeden fall das letzte
gemerkt haben dass ich mich einfach
weitergelaufen bin ich sie zum beispiel
gerade noch da diamanti hinten noch
jemand aber die sind ja auch nicht
wertvoll ist ärgerlich um die sachen die
ich mir schon gekostet habe das ist doof
dass ich das war nicht mal das war nicht
mein verschulden man da kommt ja nicht
mal was für ich sterbe einfach das
dritte mal in der vierten folge
es ist echt bitter in drei in vier
folgen einmal gestorben ich glaube mein
todes countern er dem wird so schnell
keiner einholt aber das ist unnötig dass
ich einfach so also ich dass es nichts
gegen der spiele oder so aber das ist
unnötig von mir aus gesehen dass ich das
nicht realisiert habe nach oben sind
hier sind ja man da sind auch noch
diamanten glaube ich das ist blöd und
diese 16 level jetzt ja ich bin derzeit
im tode screen teilte street sorgen ich
darf es halt nicht weiterspielen zwölf
stunden lang
das heißt ich werde in zwölf stunden
wieder aufnehmen
und werde das dann hier nach hochladen
also zwei tage später nach und dann
werdet ihr das halt sehen
ich rechne das mal ganz kurz aus wenn
ihr die letzte folge gesehen habt war
der 23 das heißt heute wenn diese folge
rates der 24 25 upload sperre weil ich
gestorben bin wegen hunger gegen hungrig
war des todes ausgerüstet ich hoffe dass
keiner irgendwie da auch stirbt dann
meine sachen wieder abzieht aber ich
glaube es sollte nicht passieren weil
auch keiner in die richtung läuft von
spawn der innenstadt deswegen sachen
sind zählt hab ich eigentlich ganz gut
gemacht finde ich vielleicht die folge
kommt dann also was man heute ist er 24
05 10 sperre am 26 am samstag kommt an
der folge wo ich dann diese sachen
einsammeln werde und dann in die stadt
laufen werde
und zwar erst mal wenn ich mir was zu
fressen holen und meine freunde dann
will ich sagen wenn es euch trotzdem
gefallen hat und euch das gefallen hat
dass ich halt alleinige war und ein
bisschen ruhiger und ein bisschen
gequatscht haben gibt den daumen hoch
und schreibt meine kommentare einfach
tipps zu hacks was soll ich als nächstes
machen ihr wisst schon jetzt client
sword das heck sind jetzt durch für mich
kein sport
na gut sozusagen jetzt beim nächsten
wieder